before we get into uh the meat of
today's show i want to briefly address
something here at the top
that relates to something we've been
talking about for years about what makes
it into the corporate media narrative
and what doesn't and one of the things
i've told you many times before
is that stories with a good beginning
middle and end a clear beginning middle
and end are much more likely to be made
stories by corporate media and so for
example when we talk about shootings a
particular shooting where we have the
shooting is going on
they've captured or killed the shooter
what's the back story on the shooter
thoughts and prayers are sent the
victims boom that it's done okay
the bigger story of the constant and i
mean almost daily mass shootings in the
united states more than daily in fact
is less of a story because it's an
ongoing story it doesn't have a very
clear beginning middle and end and i can
think of no greater illustration of this
than the fact that since the shooting in
uvalde texas last week since
there have been 17 mass shootings in the
united states
17 more shootings
since the uvalde texas shooting you can
read about them if it's uh you know it
is it is depressing reading you can read
about them at gunviolencearchive.org
and you will see that for example over
the weekend in philly there was a mass
shooting where two people were killed
and two people were injured
in henderson nevada seven were injured
in a mass shooting in phoenix arizona
there was a mass shooting when one
person was killed and five people were
injured and you can just look at the
list and as i've said before every
single one of these is its own story
you know you could look at the henderson
nevada shooting for example and it pops
up
a facebook page or it will eventually
from the henderson police department
explaining what happened and uh there
was a reported shooting and police and
fire responded and on and on and on
every single one of these is a story
and it is a constant and that's why it's
not as big of a media story individually
any of these might make news or they
might not
most of them have at least like a local
news article that's written about it but
consider
everything that's happened in uvalde
texas
learning about the shooter and what
happened and how they got in and on and
on the victims the morning
there have been 17 more such incidents
with victims and perpetrators and police
responses and affected families etc 17
of them since uvalde most of us only the
for most of us the last shooting we
really heard about was the one in uvalde
texas so
it's a it's a story with seemingly no
end
and that doesn't make it a good
corporate media story but it continues
to happen almost or even more than
once every single day
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com